years ago today a grim discovery in an
indiana cornfield marked the end of an
era for organized crime in las vegas
tony spellatro a longtime rackets boss
of las vegas was
found murdered alongside with his
brother michael the slayings weren't
solved for another 21 years
the i-team's george knapp covered
spillover during the zenith of mob
influence and he joins us now with a
look back it seems like people who were
here
remember where they were that day
a tough tony spelatro was one of the
most feared mobsters
to ever land in las vegas law
enforcement suspected him in as many as
26 murders
the story of spelatro and his crew was
fictionalized in the movie casino
the true version of his 1986 murder
wasn't revealed until a sensational
trial more than two decades later
we're worried about it you guys got to
cut it out in morning
a few words from tony spelatro were
usually enough to stop
people in their tracks he was the
undisputed king of street rackets in las
vegas
in the 70s and 80s spelatro earned his
ferocious reputation
as an enforcer on the mean streets of
chicago and was sent by outfit bosses to
las vegas
an ambassador of sorts where his primary
job was to quietly protect the skim
millions of dollars being stolen from
mob controlled casinos
but spalatro and his crew didn't keep a
low profile for long
as in the case of tony's palatro his the
hole in the wall gang
the robberies and the burglaries the
loan sharking and so on that came with
it
and they had free reign to do whatever
they wanted to do as long as they didn't
create too much notoriety
attorney jeff silver back then part of
the gaming control board was targeted
for murder
after helping to lead the investigation
of the skimming operation
when spelatro's burglary crew the
notorious hole in the wall gang
was busted during a heist the writing
was on the wall
prosecutors convinced one member frank
colada to become a government witness
admitting to murders and other crimes
and i shot him again in june 1986
bolatro was lured back to chicago
supposedly with the promise that he
would be promoted and that his brother
michael would become a made man
the two men were suspicious but drove
away to a meeting
they never returned in the movie casino
the spilatro brothers were beaten with
baseball bats in a cornfield
then buried while still alive the real
story is different
it all came spilling out in 2007 when 14
mob figures went on trial in chicago
accused of 18
murders including the spelatros the
fbi's
operation family secrets relied on
testimony from key mob
figures one defendant joey the clown
lombardo
had been spilatro's boss admitted hitman
frank colada
emerged from the witness protection
program in 2007
and gave his first interview to the
i-team we asked his opinion about who
okayed the spilato murders
joe lombardo well he was tony's boss and
he was my boss
you guys reported directly to him oh
tony did
i report it to tony uh so joe
relayed the messages to tony and uh do i
think that joe lombardo was involved and
i think that they would have to go to
him
for an okay at it yes lombardo and four
other mobsters were convicted in the
trial
according to witnesses who participated
in the slayings
the sublatros met their end in the
basement of a home
in the suburb of bensonville they were
beaten and strangled then the bodies
driven to indiana for burial
nine days later a farmer found the grave
dna from the crime scene helped build
the case
21 years later spilatro's longtime
lawyer oscar goodman who went on to
become mayor of las vegas
successfully defended tough tony in
multiple cases
and remembers a different guy than the
feared killer
well we spent so much time together
george i couldn't help but having that
kind of relationship
i must have represented tony on four or
five murder cases
by representative of racketeering cases
on black vote cases
uh only the good in tony scolagio you
know i heard the fbi
screaming and yelling that he killed 26
different people and the only thing i
could say to that is shame on them
if it killed 26 people they should have
put them in jail for a day
they they didn't even do that the murder
of the splatters was a huge story back
in 1986
in part because it was the last time the
mafia had that large of a presence on
the streets of las vegas
in the years that followed other
mobsters tried to fill those shoes
but no one came close and the
convictions in the family secrets case
pretty much gutted what was left of the
chicago hierarchy of course hole in the
wall game
yeah right about there don't wince when
i see some of those images
yeah thanks george thanks george